you can find a story and a group of
people that can help you create that
story around why you should feel
insecure about it that woman that says
I'm still a virgin and I'm worried every
guy's going to think I'm a freak based
on your narrative she has the dream
scenario she's never slept with anyone
so she no no no I want to you know I
want to because I'm the one that pushes
out this narrative I want to correct I
want to correct you Matthew no the
35-year-old virgin you know and I I have
a I had a video called your virginity
doesn't count if and this was all the
reasons why your virginity is no longer
valuable to men one of those reasons is
if you're super fat you know what I mean
like if you're a big fatty it's just not
the same like sorry you got to you got
to get in the door second if your face
looks like it was like hit by it you
know it just really deformed it kind of
It kind of loses its value um and one of
those is if you're super old because the
men assume something is wrong so so the
dream scenario is I don't know what 21
20 22 really under 25 roughly 25 and
under that that's the the highest sexual
market value and a virgin what up guys
welcome to the just PE things YouTube
channel and welcome to my reaction
series today I have a special guest on
the channel welcome to the show Dimitri
hey guys what's up tell them a little
bit about you made me a suit yeah yeah
and it was awesome and I loved it
because you know it has a sort of like a
1950s feel to it yeah it's so cute
that's very on brand for you too right
like it's it's very conservative like
but uh but I'm Dimitri tuer I'm the CEO
of ljg fashion house we're Global brand
and offices in 26 countries and four
continents around the world uh we sell
very high net worth people with their
best bespoke clothing uh publicly we're
known as the brand that makes suits for
Alice Cooper for Eddie Hall for Jordan
Peterson for Tommy Fury uh for many
Michael frenes and many others and
really what I do is I recruit young men
I recruit young men and women into the
field the career of sales because we're
a direct sales company and I teach young
men and women how to make a million
dollars a year and what I really liked
about having you on the show is you're
very there two really two really good
things about you as a guest you're very
open-minded where if you have new
information like I remember one of the
first shows we had a disagreement about
like the high value men cheating right
and I did the research and you were
right I I was shocked by that by the way
that you knew that stack as it's such a
nuance and it took me a while to well
yeah it's like there they have more of
that option well Fair it's like do do
men that can cheat cheat more than the
men with no jobs you know you know what
it was for me it's like because because
I work generally our clientele are quite
High net worth like we work with a lot
of you know Partners at law firms and
and people in private equity and just
people that sort of run Society they're
very high character people especially
around other men because what happens in
businesses if I see you break an
agreement um the Market's just going to
spit you out like as a leader you can't
break agreements because people don't
trust you and they won't follow you like
we're all free agents we can do what we
choose right and and so in the circles
that I run I just I don't see and maybe
the guys you know I've dealt with are
are very very good at hiding it I don't
know but I just I don't see any sort of
cheating relationships like I see men of
very high value acting like judicious
wise sagacious high value men but the
data suggests that yes men with more
options do tend to exercise those those
options more yeah and so that's what I
like about you because when I'm having a
conversation I like to talk to people
that like genuinely want to find out
what's true you know and sometimes
you're going to be right sometimes
you're going to wrong it is what it is
the other thing I really like is you're
very honest and so it's so funny having
you on the shows because there's very
few men that are actually honest to
women like we have a media that lies to
us corporations Li I'm I'm going to make
I'm going to postulate something uh that
that I think you're going to find really
interesting so one of the reasons men
are not honest to women and women get
continuously good feedback from men is
because those men are trying to get laid
there's strong data on that it's called
virtue signaling and and actually and
women and men both virtue signal like
for example once study that I saided on
the show before is that when you have a
fundraiser if you have attractive women
in the room men submit more money to the
fundraiser because they want they want
to show that they're more altruistic so
we show higher levels of altruism when
we're trying to get laid this is why
marriage is good the reason I can be
honest with these women is I have no
skin in the game like I'm married I got
four kids yeah I can just tell them
exactly what I think because I'm not
trying to get laid right and so that's
actually one of the reasons marriage is
good for society like when you connect
those variables marriage leads to more
truth right that's not a bad thing yeah
now I know might say well you know the
incentives today is for guys to not get
married and that's actually quite quite
relevant and and an interesting topic
for discussion but the outcomes of
successful family formation the outcomes
of marriage are very positive and so
there's a influx of female dating
coaches okay so this female dating coach
is named Matthew hussy and I wanted to
show you him because you're you're an
actual honest guy no skin in the game as
you said and I really want to get your
thoughts so he blew up I remember him
like five years ago just eight years ago
he was like the number one dating coach
so big he actually dated chamelia Cabo
if you know who that is no clue but can
I ask you is he married um he is engaged
now okay so he's engaged um now let's
I'm going to show you the video so
someone calls in and asks does your body
count matter okay I imagine that George
Clooney didn't start that relationship
by saying how many men have you slept
with hi Matthew I've been having anxiety
for the last few years the trigger to
this anxiety is the new message that is
constantly being shared and that message
is that men find women who are not
virgins gross I cannot go a few days
without it somehow popping up in my feed
that men do not want to commit to women
with a high body count or any past
sexual experience at all sometimes I do
not I feel like you've been spending too
much time on Reddit get off of Reddit I
do not have a high body count but I
still get triggered every time this pops
up I now truly believe that this is very
important to men and that if they were
to find out about a woman's sexual past
they would now start to subconsciously
value her less and not see her for as a
wife/ future mom of their babies and if
they have the option leave her uh can
you please talk about this in detail um
I I got the gist so it goes on for a bit
longer but it's pretty much the same
thing and by the way she says PS I know
that a popular comeback is that men who
care about this are insecure but I think
it's deeper than that George Clooney how
old was George Clooney when he met his
wife I don't know anything about this
relationship by the way so I don't think
this is going to turn into some sort of
interesting commentary on a celebrity
relationship but I know he was an older
man he he was what 50s his hair was
silver 60s I don't know I don't even
know how old George Clooney is I know he
didn't I know he didn't meet her in his
30s or 20s and I also know that she is
not in her 20s right so I I imagine that
George Clooney didn't start that
relationship by saying how many men have
you slept with because had he started
the conversation that way it would have
been an obvious answer plenty I'm an
adult woman who's been around for a
while I'm not someone you didn't meet a
21y old or you didn't meet an 18y old
you've met someone who's actually been
around for a minute and has had other
relationships George certain point you I
feel like men have to give up there's a
there's a time in their lives where men
have to give up on that game unless you
want to date 21 year olds for the rest
of your life at a certain point you have
to say the person well so there's like
already a logical F two logical
fallacies here right the first one it's
like well I'm a grown woman so plenty I
would ask what does plenty mean exactly
because that like I what is plenty yeah
is 50 Plenty or is five Plenty or
something like what's plenty exactly
yeah and the second one is he correlates
you know know number of of partners with
age yes there's certainly going to be a
correlation with that but not everybody
has the same values either does that
make sense no yeah and it's interesting
I've heard so much about George Clooney
and the chick that he because I think
she was like 35 well let's let's first
of all Define I know a little bit about
her she's a human rights lawyer Harvard
educ I believe Harvard educated human
rights lawyer but nonetheless an
extremely prominent one um who is also
resoundingly beautiful yeah and so so
like this is a highly like very highly
intelligent like like obviously all by
all objective like you know evidence
very highly intelligent extremely
beautiful woman and I would you know
pait that very highly intelligent
extremely beautiful women probably
aren't sleeping around because the guys
they would consider they they they you
know they the guys they would have
access to and the and the basically they
would just have their pick and they
probably be very selective I just like I
would just again like why if you're very
very intelligent this isn't like a very
beautiful dumb chick it's a very
intelligent yeah and it's an exception
but it doesn't make the rule and so I'm
like why is this guy bringing up this
exception when he knows how men think
he's a man it's also George freaking
Clooney man like like there like like
what you think it's like you know he's
not going to ask that question okay of
course he's not going to directly ask
that question he's more socially
intelligent than that like you know
interactions in Commerce trade and and
love sort of happen on the subconscious
level where we're sort of trying to
we're trying to infer information from
from half truths anyway so we know that
we can't trust what you know men say at
face value and we can't trust what women
say at face value it's just like
negotiations you're trying to infer from
the flags let's say um but I'm sure
George Clooney is also experienced
enough as a man that he's got a very
good sense of inference he can really
understand what's happening right yeah
no and let's just keep watching let's
keep watching with has existed for some
time before they met me and unless they
have been living under a rock and not
wanting to meet anyone not having any
sexual experiences is there they're
going to have had some sexual
experiences so and you know what's
really interesting I want you to notice
something you know what's funny it was
like she probably saw my videos cuz I
was bringing I was the first one maybe
not the first but you know nothing's new
Under the Sun but I had a big Series
where I talked about female virginity
right because I realized that really
multiple sexual partners is like the
link to all of the world's Pro problems
female promiscuity and I thought I was
like well you know there's always going
to be another round of 22 year olds if
they knew if the the next generation of
women knew that men would require
virginity for marriage or at least the
men they want right if like I don't know
top 5% of men said we are only accepting
virgins you don't think more women would
do it so one of the things that he said
that was interesting is like he was
reading this lady's letter whatever it
was and she's like I feel like men would
react like deeper on a subconscious
level to let's say a high body count
right and this is like a really
interesting topic in society today so
what is like the most fundamental truth
that that little boys and little girls
learn when they're little boys and
little girl little girl little boys and
little girls the most fundamental truth
we learn is that's a boy that's a girl
yeah that's the most fundamental truth
right and today as a society we're
questioning well what is a boy what
what's a what is a woman right and so we
kind of lose sense of the fundamental
truth that we implicitly know is true
that there are boys and there are girls
and some people are born born boys and
some are born girls mhm and and now
we're questioning that as a society you
following me and so when you question
the most fundamental truth you then
question the other fundamental truths
like well I think that it may be that on
a subconscious level my you know this
this guy would not like a very high body
counter like of course he wouldn't like
it and on subconscious level women know
that and here's how you know that women
know that when women want to slander
other women and they do because women
don't engage in fighting on a physical
domain women engage in fighting on an
emotional domain reputation
what do women say about other women when
they want to lower their other women's
value do they say oh I bet she's so
clean no she's a and do you know
why women will devalue other women that
way it's very simple it's competition
yeah and well and also that um Men
actually have nothing against loose
women because men are generally after
like you know selection and reproduction
whereas other women seeing other women
lowering the entry barriers to the
sexual Marketplace is a threat for those
women because they're giving away the
so of obviously but he's saying it like
well why would it like of course it
would lower the value of course why why
why are we even questioning this I know
I know but this was but it's problematic
because this guy has millions of
subscribers and I'm telling you he was
one of the leading Co like he was so big
back in the day like four or five years
ago maybe not as big as Kevin Samuels
but not far from it in terms especially
in terms of female audience but the
thing is you can such a big female
audience spewing you can't
really do that with men not as much one
thing that I think is pretty funny is I
follow you a little bit on Twitter and I
think post some very funny things but
one thing you noticed I've noticed from
from some of the conversations is all
the men and this is anecdotal but all
the men who I have seen posit that their
partner's past is completely irrelevant
have eventually been revealed with
having very promiscuous Partners say
wait say that one more time so all the
men that say look you know your
partner's past shouldn't matter all
those men eventually turn into some form
of cuck like they give out their wife or
it turns out that their wife has had a
wild history so it's almost it's almost
like they're just and this is of course
Very anecdotal from my observation but
it's like they're just justifying the
fact that they're trying they're not
arguing with the audience they're
arguing with themselves they're trying
to convince themselves yeah well that
happened the other day cuz some guy was
arguing with me about I think I was
saying something about single mothers
and I always know there's always
exceptions to every rule right there yes
yes yes but it's like the majority of
single moms are not these innocent
creatures that just found this guy that
just high and dry left them as soon as
the kid came like that doesn't happen
are there some sure but the exception
doesn't make the rule and statistically
most will not remarry it's um Dr David
Baker so he wrote the history of sex
he's like an expert um at researching
some of this stuff I can't like so give
or take these numbers like 5% but it was
roughly 15% of single moms Remar 22% get
a guy to live with them so that means
the majority do not have a happy ending
so sugar coding that does not help women
because we don't know the consequence
for the for our actions because we don't
think things through well it's I that's
deeper than we don't think things
through I'm going to make a more cereal
argument to that I I agree with you that
the outcome is the same but I don't
think the input variables are I don't
think things through I think there's a
different input variable okay go ahead I
think it's uh the sexual Revolution and
again this might be you know pretty
controversial but the sexual revolution
in the birth control pill has
conditioned women to have freedom
without consequence and the thing is men
don't have freedom to begin with like
men can't walk down the street and say
who wants to have sex with me and then
all of a sudden women show up me me me
me me that's not that's not an
experience that's not that's not how
guys that's not that's not how it goes
yeah you can't go to the club and just
have women compete for you whereas you
go to the club and then men will start
competing for the women right and so
women have always had freedom but it has
always come with consequence so biologic
biologically I don't know if our brains
are wired for I mean I'm not saying the
birth control hasn't that negative but
biologically clearly our brains are not
wired for it so it's not like you know
women are like oh I'm just going to be
evil I I think it's just like your
biology and and you know 400,000 years
of of of evolution right has been saying
to you like you want this but you
shouldn't take it because there's
consequence and now you can just take it
and so then all decisions lose
consequence right right um what was the
name Tammy was it Tammy Tanny Tanny you
this the insecurity you have about this
comes from the complete other direction
too there will be women in the love life
Club who say to me that they are a
virgin at
35 and they're terrified of what a guy
is going to think of them because they
are a virgin whatever it is you can find
well and I've heard I've heard actually
I heard Kevin Samuel say this we're over
like 25 being a roughly being a virgin
is a red flag and not for the re like
it's either she's asexual basically um
she has crazy high standards or um what
was the third one might have been
abused he said usually like something's
off that's why it's a red flag or she's
so crazy no one will touch well there
it's it's like but it's but it's also
one of those things like if you're a man
who is thinking long term like you're
optimizing for long term not only short
term one reason that might also be a red
flag that is a very very big emotional
burden for a guy to carry if he's a
mature man like taking somebody's
virginity does does I mean you might do
cool but it's actually like an emotional
burden that you carry with you right and
if somebody's at that age um and then
you understand that the burden is is at
that level like there probably is an
optimal age where at some point the the
you know the returns the Returns the the
returns of scale are negative right M
yeah well I was just thinking 35 I'm
like I I just think to a guy cuz he's
saying that girl like she has the
problem she's afraid to tell any a guy
that she's a virgin at 35 my first
question is is she fat too cuz sometimes
it's like they're a virgin but they're
fat or like something's off like to be
you know so is she lying
Yeah question how many how many chicks
have said they're virgins on the show
that I actually believe cuz they'll be
like half naked and they'll be like I'm
a virgin I'm like what born again or I
know I know we had one girl oh my gosh
we had one girl was so funny she was
talking before the show um to my friend
kit and kit was on the show um and
asking him about her dating problem with
like and I guess she mentioned she slept
with a guy or whatever on the show and I
wasn't there for this she said she was a
virgin and he like called her out for it
on the show what she say he's like
that's not what you said she got mad I
think she left or I don't remember it
was so long ago I'd have to look but so
that's another interesting thing so you
said like when women lower other women's
value they make their past sound dirtier
how do women increase their own value
like they make it sound cleaner yeah so
we know implicitly this is true yeah you
can find a story and a group of people
that can help you create that story
around why you should feel insecure
about it that woman that says I'm still
a virgin and I'm worried every guy is
going to think I'm a freak based on your
narrative she has the dream
scenario she's never slept with anyone
so she no no no I want to you know I
wantan to because I'm the one that
pushes out this narrative I want to
correct I want to correct you Matthew no
the 35-year-old virgin you know and I I
have a ver I had a video called your
virginity doesn't count if and this was
all the reasons why your virginity is no
longer valuable to men one of those
reasons is if you're super fat you know
you know what I mean like if you're a
big fatty it's just not the same like
sorry you got to you got to get in the
door second if your face looks like it
was like hit by it you know just really
deformed it kind of It kind of loses its
value um and one of those is if you're
super old because the men assume
something is wrong so the dream scenario
is I don't know what 21 20 22 really
under 25 roughly 25 and under that
that's the the highest sexual market
value and a virgin yeah so he's he's
making a straw man he's saying that
here's the argument here's how I'm going
to break it if you're 35 is a dream
scenario but he's doing it wrong
mathematically wrong and this is like so
objective right he's saying there's a
line where the more you are virgin the
more your value grows and then he's
destroying that argument but it's wrong
it's more like a standard distribution
curve where there's a like you said
there's a range yeah yeah like and I
think I said this in the video I'm like
a guy will take the really men hate fat
chicks they really
do pul like you think do you think fat
chicks like themselves oh no look I'm
not saying that I'm not saying that to'
be like blah blah body sh all the
words people assigned to it but
like poor men also hate being poor yeah
because they know because they know they
have less options right yeah um and and
it's just it is what it is yeah water is
wet the sky is blue men prefer debt-free
virgins yeah the most desirable person
in the game right now because she hasn't
done that and maybe if she's uh hanging
around 25y old for like a simple this is
just the height argument it's like well
I wouldn't date a girl who put you know
is is a little person a 3' n it's like
oh so the best outcome is a 7 fo8 chick
it's like no there's a range right
there's a
range yeah would you okay would you date
a girl that 6'5 oh that's I'm 6'4 by the
way just for for like so I'm already
like kind of on the taller end of things
um my wife is 5'10 okay so she's on the
taller and the things um that's such a
hard answer you know you like I'm not
against it because like in a sense I
would be like well who would that girl
even date if if if a 64 guy the girl I'm
thinking of cuz I played volleyball for
a girl that was 6'5 she married a guy
that was 6'10 oh well congratulations
yeah she went to a big college
congratulations yeah she wasn't that
good at volleyball um cuz she's kind of
awkward she goes to a big school cuz
they'll give you scholarship anyway if
you're tall enough as a chick cuz some
of them end up being less awkward and
get good later so it's kind of like you
know she didn't but they took her at I
think it was Witchita and yeah she just
found a guy on the basketball team and
got married well their kids are going to
be gigantic yeah I think she's pregnant
now actually they're starting a new
race but that's always the question I
ask guys like how tall is Too Tall I you
know there's there's like there's two
answers to that right like and I've had
this conversation with guys sort of
behind closed doors in a sense too it's
like getting a tall chick is also like
for a lot of men a sort of a sexual
Conquest right because you are you are
getting a woman who's like well I don't
know there's a sexual con Conquest
aspect to it but that's not the question
that you asked the question you asked
was what you know I I I I and I give a
copout answer I've always given this
answer it's a cop out answer and I'll
give it again like if a woman is taller
than me she's already freakishly tall
yeah because like I'm pretty tall so
it's like why would you it's kind of I
don't know like and plus how many women
in my life have I met like that maybe
one yeah no I was just curious cuz she
was stunningly beautiful she was yeah I
know was
she always had a boyfriend like always
like um I don't know I don't know she
would like just find the most giant she
dat a guy that's 5'7 doubt it no no no
warped people on Reddit she is going to
have a market there because they're
going to be like oh she's so attractive
she's never been with anyone the world
isn't one dating Market this is the
thing we have to get outside of out of
our heads the world isn't one dating
Market it is thousands of Niche Boutique
trading areas between people who value
different things imagine the great was
the no so okay so that's both right but
it's misleading yeah that's like saying
you know we can't we can't know where
electrons will go in a double blind
experiment well we know statistically
where most of them will go yeah it's
like it's like he's saying don't apply
don't apply group statistics on an
individual which is right but that
shouldn't mean that you shouldn't
optimize to be as attractive as you can
to as many people as possible in order
to increase your odds of period right
you know it's like yeah I'm going to
have a thousand Partners as a woman and
just hope to get a man that's really
into a woman with a high body count like
yeah that guy exists somewhere yeah but
your odds of meeting him are
significantly lower than meeting a guy
that just prefers a traditional woman
yeah have you seen do you follow neon at
all I don't know what that is okay
there's um a young streamer who's dating
a chick with an only fans okay and it's
shows me like the ne okay I know we say
influencers are in a different world and
they totally are but they do represent
something because people can relate to
it and I think you're going to see a lot
of men it's going to be a lot more
normal to date women with only fans
because this is a rich this is a very
rich like a n 20-year-old guy now
obviously he'll get more mature wise as
he gets older people make mistakes when
they're young but my question not
question I guess commentary is I think
that's going to be more normal
unfortunately in the next like 20 years
I hope not you know one of the things we
talked off camera just briefly before
this it's like as cuz you're an
influencer MH and like to a certain
degree people will replicate the
standards that you set for them because
you are popular yeah and I don't know
how much you spend time thinking about
it maybe for you it's about really just
maximizing your exposure and just bring
up you know intriguing and provocative
questions that do need I am a free
speech absolutist so I do want those
questions asked but in a way the
standard that you hold yourself to in
what you do will be reflected in society
because you do have I don't know 50
million views a month or more something
like that so so you know you see these
guys that that promote lower standards
for men and it's like that's actually
that's bad because because men already
we already hold ourselves to too low a
standard which is a problem yeah well I
that's why I think that men should
require virgins or at least the top men
I'm like okay you're telling me if
Leonardo DiCaprio came out and said look
it I have been dating all of these
chicks forever the only woman that is
going to get me is a virgin women love
to do what's trendy what's cool like
but right now we have women that are
like Nicki Minaj we have we have a
secondary societal problem here right
the reason that women of that let's say
were virgins were were maximizing their
Market potential is because the way that
men women were being taught in our
culture was that the what was the ideal
in the culture it's to get married have
a family that was the judeo-christian
approach to culture right and today
women are being told that the ideal
woman is a high powerered female
executive a bad boss right fine
but the problem is when you tell them
that that's the North Star to aim
towards all their behavior becomes
aligned with that so they take on more
masculine traits so the question I would
ask is are we raising our girls to think
that way and we're not no Abol because
the AL because the the thing that we aim
for the highest purpose we serve is no
longer the family yeah yeah I actually
do you know was so interesting um the
women voting thing I looked at more
anti-suffragist writings they equated
women voting to Communism that is
actually true yes yeah I never thought
about it like that wow I was like that
is 100% it's individual which I guess I
kind of did cuz I knew the reason why
but I never thought about communism cuz
I I don't know I just didn't think about
it but because they were saying like
communism is more individualistic where
um what they were pushing for at the
time was more family policies it it was
actually even deeper than that if if you
want to get into some real political
science theory here but the most the
most leftist of the left is actually
anarchism people think that anarchism is
on the far right it's not anarchism is
on the far left okay and it's very easy
to Define if you guys want to learn this
kind of stuff you know whatever um
conservatives are called conservatives
because their job is to conserve
specifically to conserve the
institutions that we serve right so
conserve the patriarchy as some might
call it you know but it's not but
whatever the the meritocracy is really
more of a of a better way to look at it
conserve the churches conserve the you
know judeo-christian institutions all
this kind of stuff it's all about
conservation so the opposite of
conservation is destroying the
institutions and nothing destroys more
than anarchism right so the leftest of
the left is actually complete and utter
free anarchism and so the reason it was
a communistic argument is because wom
voting would destroy the existing
institutions so the argument is like was
it specifically because they wanted
communism or they just were acting out
of vindictiveness right and and we do
see some vindictiveness happening don't
we yeah yeah well yeah yeah I'm sorry
audience I I know this is what you're
used to are expecting but no no it's
interesting I actually I love it when I
can learn more of the thought processes
behind it's really interesting to me
when I can learn the reasons why people
were fighting for and against certain
things in different time periods because
a lot of times they don't tell you the
context today well we lie about the
context we say we retroactively look at
these things and say oh the reason we
did it is because we want to encourage
equality it was never about equality no
never and you see and by the way
witchcraft too huge huge yeah yeah and
it it was um and even when I they even
knew that all the women that wanted to
vote they were all spinsters that was
like on all posters back then they well
I will say this and and we had this
conversation so people tell me Demetri
how can you you know go on Pearl show
and make it you know and resolve
yourself with the fact that Pearl says
women shouldn't vote and I actually and
we talked about this very amicably like
and very logically like I don't agree
that women shouldn't vote but I do think
that you bring up a really interesting
and a very important conversation and
that there is actually a problem and and
the problem is that women have let's say
higher trait neuroticism which means
that they're much easier to scare about
the future which means that women will
be much
influence and we
goofy because politicians Pander for
votes and they say things that they know
will destroy Society yes so so we
actually iterate ourselves like it's
just Game Theory we iterate ourselves
into voting for politicians that want to
destroy the family because they're
appealing to a to a neurotic audience
for votes right so there is a problem
there is a problem but I'll say this I
think the solution has to be education
based and I'll tell why I think it has
to be education based again I'm boring
your your audience goodbye views right
that's okay um there's a there's a
pretext that women should be sexually
pure and I agree with that pretext and
and if you push that to its logical
conclusion what you get is a culture
where women have to wear burkas so
therefore they can't advertise or Market
themselves to men and men have less of
an incentive to solicit themselves to
women and so what you get is a society
where women wear burkas it is a solution
to to um reeling in the sexual desires
and to live in a more let's say you know
in in a more holy way but it's a
cowardly solution MH and the reason it's
a cowardly solution is because it's just
the ultimate solution that just reduces
us to not have to actually grow as
people and so I agree with your with
what you postulate and saying like hey
there's a problem here I think the
solution has to be educating not just
not just women but also educating men
but we don't do that well I actually
think that most men shouldn't vote
either well I understand you're not
fighting for or I think you're net tax
contributor was that your argument or I
had a couple things I wanted um you have
to be a net taxpayer you can't be on any
benefits you can't be living off of the
government because it's not fair that
the people living off of the government
have more of a say than the people
paying into it well by the way nobody
lives off the government where's the
money come from from other people
exactly they're literally just they're
just they're just uh Paras exactly yeah
so if you're in a bunch of debt no if um
uh military I would even I would I toy
with the idea of maybe just military
members cuz you're voting for the
commander and chief I've thought about
that I'm not completely I recently heard
an argument that only land owners should
vote yeah and I I'm not sure the best
way to do it I'm open to suggestions but
I know that all of these suggestions
would limit a lot of women voting more
so than men yeah that's that's my
argument what is it in Turkey the grand
Bazar imagine the Grand Bazaar and just
everywhere there's there's a Labyrinth
of different areas trading different
things based on what people want what
you put a premium on is different from
what this person over here puts a
premium on and vice versa which means
that different people are valuable to
different people there is no one dating
Market you're treating it like there's
one dating Market because yeah that's
just wrong that's just that's just wrong
and that's he's been doing this for 10
years that's why he has to know that
he's lying like you cannot not know this
as a guy you hear the way men talk
behind the scenes the same way I hear
women say ruthless things behind the
scenes means women have locker room talk
men have locker room talk there's no way
that he doesn't know there is well we
have data from tender we know there's
one dating market like we know that
women consistently choose the same guys
and guys consistently choose the same
women yeah you spent too much time on
the internet in one particular area of
the algorithm and now the algorithm is
serving you every title it can find on
why women become unattractive the moment
they've slept with more than one person
and that's coloring your narrative all
right Matthew no there's no one well I
guess I guess I do say I do say virgins
are ideal but most men you know I hear
I've heard you know men on the show will
say under five is is is good you know I
don't actually think virgins are ideal I
think virgins are idealistic like it's
it might just not be reasonable anymore
to have that expectation but but
nonetheless well my my whole point is no
guy's going to say one one guy and
you're done it's when you've slept with
57 and you're wondering why you can't
get a high value guy anymore so the
first thing you can do by the way is
start re start stop stop searching for
those things and start searching for
positive material so that the algorithm
online starts feeding you positive
material or do it in search in an
incognito window so that the algorithm
is no longer serving you up the stuff
that is your biggest fear which it will
gladly oblige in doing for as long as
you let it um stop spending time around
people who feed that narrative or men
who feed that narrative and if in case
you feel I am coping out on your
question that you know you want me to
avoid saying that men who care about
this are insecure there are obviously
going to be some men who care about that
they're not men that I hang around none
of the men that I hang around get into a
relationship and start by saying how
many people you know my first question
are you marrying a Matthew is that
what you're doing yes no what what's
wrong with yes if it doesn't matter he's
making an argument like nobody starts by
asking the questions obviously but
that's not the point you at some point
are going to infer signs and those signs
are going to tell you subconsciously and
hopefully consciously what is the
likelihood of the relationship with this
woman that is going to work out been
within the past why have it's like why I
have standards at all like I don't hang
out like well you know it's like I
prefer women that weighs this much why I
have standards at all stop hanging out
with men that care about that stuff
remove all standards marry a chair I
like your analogies asking because what
they're trying to find is someone who's
the kind of person they want to be in a
relationship with and by the way a lot
of guys are smart enough not to even ask
the question cuz they don't want to know
the answer if it makes them feel weird
because they don't want to talk about
okay so he just admitted they care it's
all yeah correct he just admit 100% yeah
pandering this is how to Pander 101 if
you guys ever question some guys online
are like you know question you know
Pearl doesn't know this Pearl doesn't
know that Pearl you're very emotionally
intelligent because that is exactly what
he just said is they're admitting they
care because they're not confronting
Their Fear because it's like well I just
don't want to know why wouldn't you want
to know yeah because you're afraid
afraid of what afraid of afraid of your
woman losing face in front of you well
if you're afraid of it that means you
care exactly and by the way that's
probably in a lot of cases better that
we don't spend time doing this
excavation on each other's sexual past
what's the purpose of it if that's your
thing or you particularly don't mind
then you can do that but for everyone
else there's no need to do that because
it's just not relevant to where you're
going everyone has a past everyone he
said not relevant to where you're going
I have a question where you going no but
really like what's the purpose of the
relationship ideally what is the purpose
of the relationship well marriage and
kids ah so the purpose of cohabitation
and marriage is in order to reproduce
and have kids so if let's say that is
the reason he's getting married cuz I
don't think he's getting married he's
like you know what I'm just tired of
having different women in my life I just
want to do the same woman forever that's
like not why guys get married like it
the like the the aim has to be higher
than that mhm or at least not as weird
as that the aim has to be well we're
going to have a family so how does it
not matter to where you're going in fact
there's been studies now that have very
cons we've known this for like 30 years
by the way that you can predict the
propensity for one's sociosexual
Behavior meaning how they are in
layman terms you can predict that just
through a set of ribosomes in your DNA
and we can actually genetically Trace
that wow right that's really cool yeah
and so and with like a really high
predictive coefficient so it's like yeah
it matters because let me ask like a
question I would ask is like as a father
do you want an extremely sexually
promiscuous daughter and that would go
against some of our instincts right so
one of the reasons we're actually
filtering it might be on a genetic level
is we're filtering out women who would
give us an ideal Offspring and if and if
marriage and kids are the ideal then
isn't the ideal to raise a good
generation of Offspring yeah yeah well
and men can't help it like even the men
that try to turn it off or they date
these super women like you
can tell it bothers them even Adam 22
before you know you know what happened
with him right unfortunately yeah okay
but if you look at his old interviews he
was saying how he didn't want to do
stuff with his wife and another guy
because he would just feel weird about
that and then over time you you see him
change his mind but you can't get rid of
that gut reaction I don't believe it
well and some people on the left would
say that you know it's we evolve when we
get rid of our reactions no those
reactions are meant to preserve society
and and preserve fam in order to
preserve society and those people on the
left also believe that human beings are
polluting the planet well I pait
something for you our audience here
today is this people aren't the problem
people are the point right but yeah I
just I couldn't once I got red pilled I
was like I could not believe how many
pandering coaches there are I almost
think I was trying to decide what's
worse a s or a and I almost think
simps like they just enable bad behavior
and they lie to women and they profit
off of it well that's sing is a mating
strategy yeah I know it's just not it's
just not the optimal one yeah yeah like
it's it's a way it's like you know what
sing is is sing is a way to get a seat
at the table but you're at the Kitty
table like you're get invited to dinner
but you sit at the kids table like it's
probably better than just being a pure
incel all the time right but you're
sitting at the Kids
Table um tell them where they can find
you uh lgfg it's like look good Feelgood
lfg.com that's our company again I'm
Demitri lgfg the custom suit company
that makes suits for a lot of
celebrities you're going to see us
online everywhere uh my role in society
cuz you know if I were to say what is my
mission statement is to teach young men
and women to make a million dollars a
year why would you want to make a
million dollar a year what kind of
purpose is that very simple uh you have
more freedom to choose you have more
freedom to to uh not be controlled by
your government not be controlled by
nefarious agents in the dating
Marketplace Empower yourself raise the
bar for yourself and it raises the bar
for who you allow in your life guys go
follow him like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and also
leave a comment who do you think is the
most cringe female dating coach out
there and I'll react to it again like
the video bye guys